when you think fashion and models you
think New York Paris LA but did you know
many of the famous faces you see on the
runways and in ads are actually from the
heartland the middle of America and
there is an agency that specializes in
finding those beautiful people like
Ashton Kutcher and Karlie Kloss in the
most unlikely places
but somebody comes up to you and they're
like hey I want to like give you the
world then like that when you're you
should be a model and you should come to
New York do it you're immediately
dubious Ashton was still in college when
he heard those words they came from this
woman Mary Clark a fellow Cedar Rapids
Iowa native who discovered Ashton in a
bar and pretty much launched his career
Mary walked out to me and said you need
to do this I went in and like a fresh
faces contest it is really powerful to
see even him up on stage talking to
everybody and you can't help but think
it was 20 years ago and look at
everything that has happened it's pretty
incredible you could say mary has a
knack for finding talent especially in
Iowa she and her husband Jeff run mother
Model Management and they're responsible
for discovering some of today's top
faces they found Karlie Kloss at a local
benefit fashion show and Vogue cover
girl grace Hartzell was just 14 when
Mary approached her now she's sharing
runways with the likes of Gigi Hadid at
New York Fashion Week also at Fashion
Week another one of their finds
up-and-comer Alana Arrington to Oxford
Tom Ford
Sakuni easy girls that they take from
where I was two years ago to the top
it's like it's very inspiring I'll tell
you a little story about what makes them
unbelievable started doing really well
right off the bat and then I went to
Chicago and I was really struggling and
I was like on my last dime and to the
point where I was like I don't know that
I can do this anymore and I called them
and they loaned me $300 and they got me
back on my feet
and got me back going but what makes
Iowa so special well it's a secret but
all the best people come from the middle
there's a genuine heartfelt difference
and they're physically beautiful and
people are really tall because of that
court the secret is the court by the way
corn sales just went through the roof
the Clarks also told us their best
advice for aspiring models be patient it
doesn't always happen overnight like it
did for Ashton and Carly